[Música]
bien buenas tardes mi nombre es jose
tándem soy fotógrafo y hasta hace poco
estaba en la búsqueda permanente de la
inspiración la verdad es que me di
cuenta de esto cuando me invitaron a
hacer esta charla y empecé a hacer un
repaso de lo que era mi relación con la
fotografía mi relación con aquellas
historias que me habían inspirado a
hacer el trabajo que estoy haciendo
cuando empecé la fotografía lo hice
copiando a los grandes fotógrafos en mi
ecuación era que si los grandes
fotógrafos habían conseguido el éxito
con unas imágenes concretas si yo era
capaz de copiar lo que ellos hacían pues
también iba a conseguir el éxito con mi
fotografía gran error porque
nadie puede hacer la fotografía que hace
otra persona pero sí es verdad que en el
transcurso puedes encontrar tu propio
sello fotográfico yo soy un gran
defensor de las copias en fotografía
como digo cuando alguien me dice como ya
ha pasado el tiempo
oye han copiado tu fotografía han
copiado tu escenario han copiado a tu
modelo sobre la marcha lo primero que
pienso es que esa persona que copia
realmente lo hace porque quiere
conseguir un objetivo que aún no sabe
cuál es en el transcurso de el camino
hacia la copia que no al plagio que son
dos cosas totalmente distintas esa
persona va a fallar va a acertar se va a
equivocar otra vez y por tanto va a ir
teniendo un aprendizaje sin saber lo que
concluirá en su forma de trabajar en un
futuro y que marcará sin duda toda su
trayectoria
eso y que por otra parte y por la parte
de la de la vanidad nadie ni el más
tonto copia a los malos de manera que el
hecho de que te copien no deja de ser
también un reconocimiento
entonces como digo empecé copiando a los
grandes fotógrafos evidentemente no lo
conseguí yo quería hacer
eugenio recuenco solamente pude ser josé
tándem tampoco es que haya sido mala
cosa pero realmente estaba muy por
debajo de lo que él de lo que es no
entonces
la segunda relación con la inspiración
fue a través de las agencias
publicitarias de las agencias de moda
a mí me atraía todo lo que reunía todo
lo que rodeaba a las fotografías de moda
todo ese glamour pero sobre todo ese
trabajo que había detrás de la
elaboración de cada una de las fotos
toda la gente que participaba la
posibilidad de dirigir un equipo grande
que fuera capaz de hacer realidad lo que
yo pensaba
una cerca de la agencia de moda le
enseñé mi trabajo pero no les interesó
no les interesó por una razón muy clara
y es que según después lo pude ver ellos
todavía se encontraban en la primera
fase en la que yo la que yo ya había
pasado que era la copia de ejemplos de
modelos que estaban al otro lado del
océano y que marcaban un poco las pautas
de la industria es decir me di cuenta
sobre la marcha de que la inspiración
estaba directamente ligada a la
creatividad y a ellos realmente no les
interesaba la creatividad sino hacer ese
patrón que todos podíamos hacer y que yo
podía haber hecho sin sin lugar a dudas
porque a veces a escondidas en el
estudio lo hacía lo intentaba y decía
bueno pues tampoco es tan complicado lo
que ellos quieren no pero sin embargo
dentro de mí había algo que me decía que
ese no era mi trabajo eso no era lo que
yo tenía que hacer yo no tenía que hacer
lo que estaban haciendo los demás no
porque fuera mejor ni peor sino
simplemente porque no me interesaba
entonces en el proceso de ser ello o ser
yo me decanté por ser yo eso me obligó a
trabajar muchísimo y a realizar muchas
muchas fotografías como decía pablo
picasso antes lo nombraba y por fin ha
salido la famosa frase la idea era que
cuando la inspiración llegara pues me
pillara trabajando si me pillaba
trabajando era más fácil que alguien se
pueda fijar en mi trabajo
ahora le he traído un vídeo en el que
recoge parte de estas fotografías
y he ido haciendo a lo largo de todo
este tiempo se trata de fotografías
por un lado comerciales por otro lado
fotografías editoriales
también hay fotografías publicitarias
y son la manera aproximada en que yo veo
la realidad que me rodea
[Música]
esta foto por ejemplo interesaba más a
las agencias que cualquier otra de las
que están viendo
evidentemente resulta más sencilla
que cualquiera otra
durante todo este tiempo he seguido
haciendo este trabajo evidentemente el
trabajo publicitario hay que hacerlo
pero también hay que hacerlo en base a
lo que a cada cual le gusta porque
ocurre una cosa es posible que si
hacemos el trabajo que le gusta a los
demás
ganemos más dinero pero la satisfacción
será menor entonces al cabo del tiempo
es posible que alguien se acerca a
nuestro estudio y nos contrate una
fotografía porque la hacemos nosotros no
porque quieren algo parecido a lo que
todos tienen
esto de la inspiración
va por ratos también hay ocasiones en
las que uno tiene muy claro lo que
quiere hacer
y hay otras en las que no es tan fácil
porque realmente pasas un período de
seguía todos pasamos un desierto lo que
ocurre es que como decía alguien nuestro
buen gusto nuestro sentido de la
plasticidad nos lleva a repetir esa
imagen que no hemos conseguido y haber
que nuestro trabajo no es realmente tan
bueno como el de esas personas que
queremos imitar y es precisamente ese
buen gusto el que nos tiene dentro del
juego el que nos permite seguir
trabajando en pos de conseguir esa buena
imagen
estos son trabajos publicitarios
y estos son cosas que hago cuando me
aburro y me viene la inspiración
bueno algo más de publicidad
y un poco más de imaginación es probable
que al ver todas estas imágenes
algunos de ustedes algunas de ellas al
menos les haya gustado e incluso que
fueran capaces de colgar algunas en casa
en el salón donde sean o en mi caso ya
no me dejan colgar más fotos
porque además dicen que son de gente que
no conocen en mi casa y quieren fotos de
mis hijas tienen fotos de nosotros en
grupo en las fiestas etcétera pero no
fotos artísticas digo esto porque es
probable que alguno de ustedes
quisiera colgar algunas de estas fotos
de su casa pero quizás sea menos
probable que se sientan identificados
con las modelos con las personas que
aparecen en ella y les cuento por qué
porque resulta que en el mundo hay
muchos millones de personas de esos
millones de personas probablemente dos o
tres sean modelos probablemente 500 o
1000 sean top models y probablemente
podamos recordar el nombre de dos es
decir no estamos para nadie
identificados con esos modelos porque
salvo honrosas excepciones nadie tiene
unas piernas tan largas una piel tan
tersa un cuello tan estilizado
un gusto tan adecuado a cada necesidad
y les voy a confesar una cosa ellos
tampoco
ellos tampoco ellos son productos de
nuestra inspiración ellos son producto
de nuestra imaginación y los hemos
creado nosotros de modo que si te paras
a pensar un poco qué fue lo que me pasó
a mí te das cuenta de que la sociedad y
nosotros como primeros culpables cuando
nos dedicamos a hacer el trabajo que nos
piden las agencias y no lo que realmente
nos gusta está eligiendo como modelo a
personas que aparecen en las portadas de
las revistas pero que realmente no
existen y si miramos a nuestro alrededor
vemos que ni nuestras hijas ni nuestras
padres y nuestros compañeros de trabajo
ni nadie es tan perfecto como esta gente
que aparece en la fotografía yo
y me di cuenta de esto rápidamente
porque solía hacer catálogos de grandes
almacenes que seguramente todos ustedes
habrán tenido en la mano y cuando
hacíamos las producciones fotográficas
la persona que me mandaban para hacer de
modelo de señora tenía 24 años y era lo
que conocemos como un pibón
y la persona que venía a ser de joven
tenía 16 años y no se parecía nada a las
chicas de 16 años que yo conocía no
así que en esas estaba yo creando
imágenes de las que a mí me gustaban
cuando de pronto me llega un correo
electrónico a través de mi página web de
una señora que me dice oiga he visto su
trabajo lo visto en las redes lo he
visto en su web
me gusta mucho me parece fantástico pero
claro con esas modelos esos escenarios
esa ese vestuario y eso es estilismo ya
podrá usted hacer las fotos bien como
para no mejor pues tiene razón dice pero
ya me gustaría a mí ver lo que usted es
capaz de hacer con mujeres de más de 40
como era el caso de la persona que me
escribió y que nunca supe quién era digo
bueno pues
me hizo me hizo reflexionar no me hizo
pensar y aunque es verdad que el estudio
y la gente de todas las edades de todas
las condiciones de todas las tipologías
y morfología
me quedé pensando si sería capaz de
crear una colección de imágenes dónde
todos nos mostramos tal cual somos
sin ningún tipo de retoque fotográfico
y por otra parte por una parte si somos
capaces de mostrarnos y por otra parte
si somos capaces de verlo
desde cuenta que estamos en pleno siglo
de la imagen del postureo de la
felicidad de las redes sociales asesinas
de la fotografía porque en la actualidad
se hace mucha más fotografía que ninguna
otra época de la historia pero también
es verdad que se hace la peor fotografía
de la historia y sobre todo fotografía
que nunca más vamos a volver a ver
entonces vemos tan malas fotografías que
nos parece bueno al final es tanta que
cuando vemos una buena no somos capaces
de reconocerlo pero bueno me estoy
desviando del tema y a lo que iba era a
ver si la gente tenía la capacidad de
verse reconocerse y mostrarse y entonces
así surgió la verdad desnuda la verdad
es nada es una colección de fotografías
de cuerpos de cuerpos humanos sin ropa
fotografiado de cuello hacia abajo de
una manera que haga irreconocible su
rostro
para enseñar
para ver para reflexionar sobre ellos y
para reconocernos dentro del proyecto
donde ya ha fotografiado a más de 500
personas
hay una pieza que tiene siete metros de
largo por el momento porque la mantengo
abierta y voy incorporando nuevos
cuerpos y desde aquí invito a todos los
que quieran participar en ella que nos
escriban a través de la página web
es una pieza como digo de 7 metros de
largo donde aparecen todas las
morfologías de cuerpos posibles o por lo
menos todas las que yo he encontrado que
ya les digo que son casi todas entonces
la idea es que todos nosotros podamos ir
a ver ese cuadro encontremos nuestro
cuerpo desnudo sin haber posado en él
eso nos va a dar una idea de lo iguales
que somos
así que
este es el proyecto de la verdad desnuda
que tanto nos ha hecho rodar últimamente
por españa y si es posible en breve por
otras partes de europa les paso la
proyección
[Música]
se trataba como digo de fotografiar
gente que venía al estudio y que lo más
importante no se conocían hasta el
momento en que se quitaban la ropa
no hay ningún tipo de retoque
fotográfico lo que ven es lo que hay
[Música]
de cualquier manera aprovecho para decir
que el photoshop y el cualquier programa
de retoque fotográfico es algo que
todavía seguimos utilizando en él
en el estudio pero lo hacemos con
intención y de él
mejorar la fotografía básicamente en el
color
21 el cuerpo ha equivocado el cuerpo
[Música]
y cuerpos que parecen paisajes al final
el cuerpo bastante vivido
que con un detalle sólo nos puede
enseñar mucho tu cuerpo dolorido
[Música]
cuerpos totalmente opuestos son cuerpos
que vemos todos los días en la guagua en
el mercado en el colegio en el trabajo
de distintas razas
de distintos sexos de todos los sexos
quemado
[Música]
o puestos totalmente el cuerpo como
lienzo
el cuerpo retocado sin necesidad de
photoshop
y cuerpos que a lo largo de las edades
van cambiando estos son cuerpos de 20 a
30 años de 30-40
de 40-50
[Música]
de 50 a 60
de 60 a 70
y de 75 años entonces está lo que acaban
de ver no es realmente una colección de
fotos de desnudo pero es una colección
de cuerpos desnudos es una colección de
almas desnuda
por eso cuando nos referimos a este
proyecto hablamos de almagra fia porque
detrás de cada fotografía detrás de cada
persona que venía a quitarse la ropa
detrás de cada persona que se desnudaba
en el estudio hay una historia de la
mujer rechazada absolutamente por su
marido que por primera vez se atrevía a
mostrar sus miedos en público del enano
del que todo el mundo se reía cuando
estaba en el colegio cuando surgió su
vida
del minusválido al que nadie se para
ayudar ni se para a pensar cómo es su
vida de la mujer que se cree menos mujer
porque se le ha estirado un pecho
un montón de sentimientos revueltos que
nos han hecho pensar que realmente lo
que estábamos haciendo era fotografiar
personas por dentro es probable que en
esta segunda tanda de fotografías en
este segundo vídeo se hayan visto
ustedes más reflejados que es la primera
la primera era más artística de acuerdo
la segunda era más real más cruda pero
si nos paramos a pensarlo es lo que
tenemos alrededor son nuestras madres
nuestras hermanas nuestros primos
nuestros compañeros de trabajo
como les dije en un principio mi nombre
es josé tándem soy fotógrafo y hasta
hace poco estaba buscando la inspiración
pero ya ha dejado de hacerlo porque
después de mucho buscar lo me dado
cuenta de que la inspiración era esto
muchas gracias
[Música]